las filas de vehículos en las
gasolineras se alargan a en reino unido-
ante el temor de que se agote el
combustible
es vergonzoso como si viviéramos en un
país del tercer mundo
la alarma se desató el jueves cuando la
petrolera bp anunció la clausura
temporal de algunas estaciones ante la
falta de suministro sin embargo las
autoridades aseguraron que no hay
escasez de gasolina ni de diésel en el
país sino que el desabastecimiento
responde a la falta de camioneros los
sindicatos de transportistas afirman que
reinó unido- necesita 100 mil
conductores más si quieres satisfacer la
demanda que se vio afectada por la
pandemia
durante el cierre los conductores no
pudieron pasar las pruebas de los
vehículos pesados y eso es lo que ha
provocado este problemas sin embargo
varios británicos consideran que la
situación también se debe al presi con
la salida de reino unido de la unión
europea se calcula que 20.000
conductores europeos regresaron a sus
países de origen ya que las empresas
británicas ya no pueden contratar a sin
un permiso de trabajo
desde que se produjo el break sida ha
habido una escasez de mano de obra en
todas las industrias se debería haber
pensado en ello pero este gobierno nunca
ha pensado en el futuro no fuera por su
parte el gobierno intenta restar
importancia al impacto del presi en la
escasez de conductores sin embargo
anunció que planeaba ofrecer hasta 5 mil
permisos de trabajo temporales a
transportistas extranjeros una medida
que las empresas de logística reclamaron
durante meses pero que el gobierno había
descartado previamente